we have now over 5,100 david pakman show
viewers and listeners who are discussing
politics and lots of other stuff as well
on our subreddit so rather than having
like a standalone message board or
discussion forum on our website we use
the reddit infrastructure for a de facto
message board and forum for our audience
and you can find it at david pakman.com
slash reddit that will redirect you over
to our subreddit and a few of the
interesting threads i spotted this
morning there and i do hope that you'll
subscribe to our subreddit and
participate in these conversations an
interesting post this morning about
Trump scoring 30 out of 30 on his mental
health assessment adding David are you
ready to admit that you're wrong well we
are going to be following up about that
later in the program I have no like
personal stake in Trump being demented
or not in fact I've actually said before
it's almost worse if he's not suffering
from dementia because it means the
things he's been doing are because he's
genuinely a bad person or maybe a
suffering from personality disorder so I
actually I'm indifferent it's very clear
that the behavior is incredibly
concerning whether it's dementia or
narcissistic personality disorder or
whatever that will hopefully eventually
find out evil or not fit for office it's
like pick your poison it's one of the
two right I don't know why everybody's
so thrilled that at least according to
one one relatively bogus study the
Montreal cognitive assessment he seems
to be fine mentally also from our reddit
discussion forum we had a voicemail
earlier in the week from someone said
they were very disappointed that I fell
for the Republican talking points on
voter fraud and that it doesn't exist
and I was really surprised because I've
been sort of completely unequivocal for
10 years on the program that I don't
think in-person voter fraud is a problem
and someone on our subreddit pointed out
you did an entire like 20 minute
long-form investigation yeah and the
title is voter fraud isn't a problem
voter suppression
I was just referencing the stories that
we had done in like the few weeks prior
to that choice mail I forgot all about
this long-form investigation that we did
yeah it's like we took more than a month
put together a super detailed analysis
of how voter fraud is not a problem so
anyway I don't know how someone came
away with that impression
also from the david pakman show
subreddit do you have any statistics on
the age and gender breakdown of david
pakman show viewers well we have some
data not surprisingly like most online
heavily online news shows we have a
bigger male audience than a female
audience I don't think anybody who's
familiar with the demographics and shows
like ours would not be surprised by that
and age-wise although we have viewers
and listeners all over the age spectrum
the age brackets definitely skew younger
and I don't remember the exact numbers
but I think something like I think more
than half like maybe 55 or 60 percent of
our audience Wow is under 50 or
something like that oh yeah I imagine
it's more than that yeah maybe it's even
under 45 now I'm not sure but anyway the
audience skews male more than average
education level more than average income
from our analyses and younger how do we
go about income and education level we
have it out on we've partnered with our
podcast platform okay and to survey the
audience a number of times and that
always seems to be now of course people
could lie about their income it's
totally anonymous so I don't know why
anybody would anyway last thing from our
david pakman show subreddit does david
pakman use a teleprompter or something
to that effect yeah I don't use a
teleprompter per se but what I do have
is right below the camera I have a small
monitor where I have all sorts of notes
so like how I'm introducing guests
things I want to talk about on the
program the list of stories that we're
doing if pat is going to put up an image
on the screen or a video I've got that
so I know what's going on and then I
have a sort of list of bullet points
that sometimes includes specific quotes
or whatnot and that is sort of like the
guide for me going through the show I'm
glad that you have that because
otherwise I have to stand here with like
a poster yeah well no so what I used to
have is I used to have a bunch of
paperwork
below me and I would do the Limbaugh
thing where I like very loudly shuffle
the paperwork to make it clear that
there's actually like you know data are
being done reading being done um and I
got away from that because I felt like I
was looking down a lot and it was sort
of a distraction to the audience but
yeah either way we've gone back to it a
few times we've had our outages and yes
well internet when there was a power
outage of course the cameras didn't work
either but I think what you're referring
to is the internet outage we had where
our cameras work but I wasn't able to
access my notes which we keep online but
anyway please subscribe to our subreddit
david pakman.com slash read it i am a
participant there pat is a participant I
don't think producer Noah is on the
reddit but we want to keep him isolated
from that because it can be very very
toxic and we don't want to corrupt him
you know I would be scared about